for me working on on your body is the
beginning of everything so how can you
achieve greatness how can you take some
of what Will Smith does the magic and
apply to your business your life your
aspiration your goals I'm gonna give you
three tips to help you if you don't have
a healthy body a healthy mind there's no
way in hell you'll be able to sustain
the stress the pressure it takes to be
successful rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's evan i believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee on sip on today's message work on
your body over to you will smith also if
you want to know what Will Smith and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange you know as
an artist it was it was a fun to get out
on that on that limb and hoping it
doesn't break under your feet
it gets more and more difficult I used
to be able to eat whatever I want and
then in six weeks I could get in any
shape I wanted to get into but that's
not the case anymore where we're around
the twelve or fourteen week mandatory
training to do anything but but I love
it I enjoy I enjoy the discipline of it
for me working on on your body is the
beginning of everything you know your
mind starts to work better you're the
better husband a better father a better
friend and life is just better when you
you know care for your body at the
highest level greatness is about effort
not luck greatness is about waking up
every day and making progress towards
your dreams towards your ambitions
towards your goals especially when it's
hard especially when everybody would
give you the day off when everybody
would understand your circumstance and
what happened today everybody gives you
a pass but you don't give yourself a
pass because what you are doing is so
important whether you love Will Smith or
not the reason why he's had success is
not because of luck it's because he
works hard he works harder than anybody
on the set he worked so hard when he
started the Fresh Prince of bel-air that
he memorized
everybody's lines on the set everybody
not just his lines he memorized
everybody's lines and he was caught a
couple times in the first couple
episodes Melvin the other people's words
as they were talking and they had the
Kalima to say don't mouth the words we
can see it on the camera he knew
everybody script he worked harder than
anybody else and that's why he became
one of the most bankable stars in
Hollywood now take a look at what he's
doing on Instagram where most of the big
Hollywood stars don't want to do
Instagram don't want to post up their
private life don't want to create
content feel that it's beneath them only
want to make big blockbuster movies
what is Will Smith doing he's making
content he's making content in his
closet he's making content in his car
he's making content at his house he's
making content he's embracing that this
is the new way to win and while all the
other Hollywood stars have to have it
they
and they're sitting on the high mountain
and the perch and judging and being too
good for other things Will Smith has the
humbleness Will Smith will put any
effort in ultimately Will Smith will win
so how can you achieve greatness how can
you take some of what Will Smith does
the magic and apply to your business
your life your aspiration your goals I'm
gonna give you three tips to help you
number one
attach yourself to the effort not the
result attach your identity yourself
what you value to the effort that you
put in not the result at the beginning
of anything when you're first getting
started you won't get results it's not
gonna work you're gonna have failure
after failure after failure if you judge
yourself by the results if you tie
yourself worth to you winning winning
that race then you're constantly gonna
be playing small because you're gonna
look for easy races if your identity is
attached to winning that race you will
play small forever because you will
enter into races that you can always win
because that's how you get off that's
how you get happy instead understand
that by putting in massive effort
eventually you'll get tons of failures
but eventually you will win and tying
how you see yourself how you think about
yourself how you respect yourself to the
effort that you are putting in daily if
that's how you think about yourself you
will achieve massive success and get the
results you're after
number two is scheduled for success
think about what your goals are what
your dreams your ambition what you want
to accomplish here's what you want to
have happen right people are great
entrepreneurs are great at visualizing a
coming up with big lofty ambitions and
dreams and goals now you can look at
your actions you have to schedule for
success
show me your calendar look at your
calendar schedule it in if it's not
scheduled in it's not gonna happen if
you don't schedule and make time for the
important things in your life it won't
happen not just your business ambitions
but your personal life if you don't have
it in your calendar if it's not gonna be
scheduled in it will not happen and so
you need to schedule yourself in for
success your ambitions your goals your
dreams look at now what you're doing on
a weekly basis from Sunday to the next
Sunday from Monday to Monday right the
actions that are in your calendar ask
yourself
if I did these actions every day or
every week right if I follow this
calendar through if I did everything
that's in that schedule would it lead to
me making progress to accomplishing my
mission your big goal if you did these
things every week if you did those
things would it help you move closer to
your goal or not and for too many people
the answer is no for too many people
it's great to have ambitions and dreams
you believe in it you think that can
happen you love it it's amazing but it's
not happening it's not the results
aren't coming as you know we're even
close because the effort that you're
putting in you mean putting in lots of
effort but the effort that you're
putting in what's in your calendar
whether it's full-time or part-time one
hour a day or 18 hours a day like
whatever is in there what's in your
calendar getting that work done is not
mapping to you becoming the success that
you want to be you need to schedule for
success your calendar your schedule the
things that you're doing every single
day and every week need to map to you
accomplishing your goals schedule for
success and number three is chart your
start chart your start your morning
routine what you do the very first thing
as you start your day is really
important most people wake up like an
accident most people wake up pick up
their phone so at responding to other
people's emergencies and here's the
secret here's a trick that I think a lot
of people aren't aware of everybody
wakes up the same I don't wake up super
pumped and fired up and motivate like
yeah another day is amazing I wake up
and I'm tired and I have lines on my
face from the pillows and the sheets and
I'm wiping you know crust out of my eyes
like I wake up like everybody else don't
be hard on yourself
if you are waking up and you're not
motivated don't be hard on yourself if
yesterday you had the greatest day of
all time and you got fired up and you
watch the video or you met somebody and
you just had an insanely productive day
don't be hard on yourself if the next
day you wake up and that fire is energy
is gone that's normal that's average
that's typical like that's what most
people do the difference is the people
who go off and achieve their dreams they
have something in the morning that
quickly realigns themselves they don't
allow that morning state that they wake
up in to be their state for the entire
day
they don't allow that to happen you need
to chart your start you need to figure
out what is the thing that gets you so
fired up what is the thing that gets you
feeling courageous and bold and willing
to take risks and go off and accomplish
your dream if that's watching a video
that's reading the book if that's having
a conversation that's meditating and
that's going for a walk if that's
working out like no judgement whatever
the thing is for you put that into your
morning routine chart your start do that
thing the very first thing every single
day if you did the thing that made you
feel the courageous and bold every
single morning your life would be
unrecognizable one year from today the
difference is you think people wake up
and they're fired up naturally they're
not the difference between you and Will
Smith is that he has a morning routine
that empowers him and you're waking up
like an accident
flip it now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day I want to know what
is a change that you need to make to
your morning routine starting tomorrow
let me know put it down in the comments
below
the Greeks used to say it's mind and
body right it's not yes right and which
drives me crazy ISM there's so many
successful monetarily successful people
out there businesspeople that have
clearly mastered that or mastered
anything that requires the brain but
they're not taking care of their body
right can you imagine how much more
powerful they'd be if it was connected
oh yeah right you know people who think
they can control it all it's just the
surface of the brain the deeper parts
include the sensation and experience
with your body then the brainstem is
gonna work the limbic system is going to
work and when they all come together
there you got expanding consciousness
spirituality and you can become very
very powerful I saw a couple comments on
YouTube people asking what then do you
recommend these like mind stimulating
your mind and hinting drugs the answer
is absolutely not if you follow my work
you know I don't smoke I don't drink and
I don't do drugs I don't even drink
coffee why I drink like honey green tea
that's what I drink and water and maybe
from time to time you know cook zero
when I'm watching a movie or something
like that that's it no drugs no
cigarettes and no alcohol why is that
because you notice a lot of times even
with my own story my father was actually
a very heavy smoker I want to say he
said hey he was an alcoholic but he
drinks quite a bit he enjoys a glass
here and there and I do notice later on
when he had the stroke he had all the
when his health was in it was declining
a lot of those habits contributed to
that if you don't have a healthy body a
healthy mind there's no way in hell
you'll be able to sustain the stress the
the pressure it takes to be successful
so I don't think you need those things
you only need those mind enhancing drugs
to be successful to have more clarity
and all this if you want to enjoy a
drink here and there that's perfectly
fine I'm
say I don't do it I don't need to have
alcohol to have a good time and when I
drink I like people hey Dan just a zip
of beer it's okay enjoy they don't taste
good to me quite frankly I mean they
taste like that right they don't even
taste good to me so I don't enjoy I
don't need those things to have a good
time
if I have a good time good company good
friends good conversation I have a good
time and I don't need to get high to do
too I get high on doing what I love I
get high on just life I get high on
being the impact to people if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple so it
would be kind of like a little beacon if
you want more Will Smith check out the
top ten rules we did vol 5 it's right
there next to me I think you're gonna
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I'm willing to die in the
process of acquiring skill